-Our next guest is nominated for
three Grammys,
including Best New Artist.
Performing "Time Machine"
from her album
"Public Displays of Affection,"
here's Muni Long.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ Eventually the good girls
make bad decisions ♪
♪ Like messin'
with the bad boys ♪
♪ Who love all the women ♪
♪ And then somewhere,
there's a transition ♪
♪ Turn the good girls
into bad women ♪
♪ But she would do it over ♪
♪ If she had three wishes ♪
♪ She is me ♪
♪ One ♪
♪ I wish I never fell in love ♪
♪ Two, I ♪
♪ I wish I never fell for you ♪
♪ Oh, three ♪
♪ If I just had one more wish ♪
♪ I'd go back and do it
all over again ♪
♪ Wish I had a time machine ♪
♪ Baby, if I had
a time machine ♪
♪ I would hop inside
my time machine ♪
♪ And rearrange history ♪
♪ Get rid of some of
these memories ♪
♪ Anything that ain't
servin' me ♪
♪ I wish I had a time machine ♪
♪ Go back to
when you lied to me ♪
♪ Oh, I was so sad ♪
♪ That's the day a good girl
turned bad ♪
♪ Tried to act like I ain't
care, but I was bothered ♪
♪ Usher, I had it bad,
you had me caught up ♪
♪ It done turned me to a savage
like Rihanna ♪
♪ Ugh, I put that
on your father ♪
♪ When the situation's so bad ♪
♪ If you stay,
it's disrespectful ♪
♪ I thought I was special ♪
♪ And that's why
it was so hard ♪
♪ For me to let go, oh-oh ♪
♪ And then somewhere,
there's a transition ♪
♪ Turn the good girls
into bad women ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
♪ But she would do it over ♪
♪ If she had three wishes ♪
♪ She is me ♪
♪ One ♪
♪ I wish I never fell in love ♪
♪ Two, I ♪
♪ I wish I never fell for you ♪
♪ Oh, three ♪
♪ If I just had one more wish ♪
♪ I'd go back and do it
all over again ♪
♪ Said I wish ♪
♪ Said I wish I ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Get rid of these memories ♪
♪ I wish I had ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ So sad ♪
♪ That's the day a good girl
went bad ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ I wish, I wish ♪
♪ I wish I could have it ♪
♪ I'd go, I'd go ♪
♪ Whoa, oh, oh ♪
♪ Yeah, yee, yee-hee ♪
♪ I wish I had a time machine ♪
[ Vocalizes ]
♪ Where the...I get
a time machine? ♪
♪ I want a ♪
♪ Ah-ha, ah-ah, ah-ah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Wish I had a time machine ♪
♪ Whoo-hoo ♪
[ Echoing ]
♪ Wish I had a time machine ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]